um
i don't have anything at the top um and
they'll pull these up in a moment as we
talk about kovid which i assume we will
talk about during this briefing but we
and we will keep you all make sure you
have plenty of time to get set for the
president's remarks he's running a
little bit late today so we'll let you
know we we have an update but colleen
wants to kick us off okay thanks jen um
so first off how is the president
feeling given close contact is he
synthetic is he doing okay i know he's
getting tested tomorrow but you can give
us an update uh he's asymptomatic i
spent several hours with him this
morning
and he is feeling great and you'll see
him at the speech shortly and then um
second question is
the 500 million test kits that are being
distributed in january
um you know is that going to be enough
how um are you guys going to work to get
more
given um what looks to be a really
serious testing kit shortage right now
especially
absolutely so what the president is
announcing today everyone should see as
building on the steps we've taken over
the last couple of months over the last
couple of months we've quadrupled our
testing capacity i'll talk about that in
a moment it's not related to your
question that would have been very
impressive
but we've quadrupled over the last few
months our testing capacity as some have
asked so let me clarify too the 50
million tests that we were distributing
this month to community health centers
uh and rural health uh health centers
this is in addition to that those 50
million tests that are being distributed
the 20 000 sites that that are already
up and right running this is in addition
to that that the president is announcing
today so i i reference that colleen
because it's important for the american
people to hear and understand we're
going to continue to build so the 500
million test kits
that will begin to be available in
january is a significant the largest uh
purchase we have done to date and it is
uh building on what we've done today in
an effort to make testing more free free
accessible uh to people across the
country go ahead drill down on some
specifics on this 500 half a billion if
you will yes we like that big number
half a billion okay so when can
americans expect to see these tests
where are they coming from
how many can a family or person order it
once is this website going to be able to
sustain all of these people who will
want to get on and get these tests uh
to answer your last question yes that is
our expectation and we are preparing for
that uh we are we will have more
information as it is available including
uh what the website looks like we will
make the website available as soon as
these tests are available they will
start to be available in january uh and
in terms of the numbers that different
families can order that is we are
working through all those very important
details right now dr fauci said today
that it's going to be a matter of a
couple of weeks when we start to see a
decline from omicron
are these tests this batch of 500
million going to actually make a
difference in the surge that we're
seeing right now or are they coming too
late for this
well again our objective here the
president's objective has been to build
on the steps he's taken over the last
couple of months again quadrupling test
quadrupling testing capacity making it
more available in more communities
opening more testing sites across the
country and really directing our efforts
and our resources toward the parts of
the country where they need help the
most so i know part of the announcement
today is obviously
testing sites and opening additional
testing sites we have additional testing
sites i've been running in new york city
we'll have them up and running in new
york city for example by the end of this
week
additional testing sites will come
online next week as states we are
coordinating with to determine logistics
scale and timing uh can be finalized and
part of our effort now is also to make
assessments about where additional
testing sites will be needed so we have
teams out on the ground to make that
assessment with governors state leaders
local health officials who are
experiencing spikes or who anticipate
experiencing spikes and that's just the
testing center component where people
can go and get them in person and again
this is building on the testing capacity
we've already built to date in january
sorry last question um you're still
seeing these long lines all around the
country so at the end of 2021 as we
close out this year i still have to ask
when can every american who wants to get
an
test to get one because they can't get
one today well as i just noted one step
we're taking is really surging capacity
and opening these testing sites in parts
of the country where they have been
hardest hit new york city is one of them
and those testing sites will be up and
running in new york city by the end of
this week and we will continue to surge
capacity and open additional testing
sites in other parts of the country and
that is something that can happen very
rapidly and our teams ready to
deploy those resources
there are still 20 000 sites across the
country where people can go there are
still
50 million tests that we are
distributing to rural community health
centers and we're doing this as quickly
as possible 500 million tests in january
is the largest order we have ever made
to date and we're going to do it as
quickly as we can but they won't be
available until january where are they
coming from these 500 tests the eight
approved by the fda uh the eight tests
approved by the fda hold up and getting
those people
well the the those those final approvals
uh just uh just went through uh in
november um so that has been part of our
ability to expand our capacity in
addition to using the defense production
act and our investment in three billion
dollars to do that it's possible to
reduce the 10-day isolation period is
that something that's under active
consideration i know that dr fauci spoke
to that briefly that would be a decision
made by our health and medical experts
in the cdc so i would certainly point
you to them we're always assessing and
looking at different steps that can be
taken go ahead jeff is the president
satisfied at the speed at which all this
is happening it was nearly four weeks
ago over thanksgiving vacation in
nantucket when he
uh first talked about the overcrowd
variant uh we've known christmas
obviously is coming for a long time and
yet these sites will not be set up until
the end of this week which is christmas
is he satisfied at the speed in which
this is all happening well what the
president's promise to the american
people is jeff is to constantly
re-examine and improve our code response
uh including testing and testing access
and always look for a way to do better
and the announcement today is an effort
to do exactly that uh we have taken a
number of steps over the past several
months and his view is we need to do
more and we need to do it more as
ambitiously and aggressively as possible
and his announcement today is a
reflection of that and and should be
seen as his own assessment that we
should be doing more you know a couple
weeks ago you stood here at the podium
when there was a discussion about uh
sending a test to people's homes and you
said should we just send them to every
american
as you've reflected on the change in
omicron here uh have you reflected on
your tone in that answer
well jeff i would say there's not a day
that goes by that i don't uh leave this
podium and wish i would have said
something with greater context or
more precision or additional information
and
that day there was a lot of good
questioning on testing and uh during
that briefing i conveyed a lot of
information about our expansion of
testing about the 50 million tests that
we were making available about the 20
000 free testing sites and should i have
included that additional context again
in that answer yes going back i wish i
would have done that to be clear so
people have accurate information about
how it works out there which i know is
your objective as well as mine
we're making tests free and accessible
without the risk of them going to waste
in the home of people who do not want
them so people will go to a website
which again we will put out there in
january when the information is
available and they will be able to
request free tests that's something that
is a reflection of the president's
commitment to continue re-examining uh
and improving our covert response
including as it relates to testing go
ahead and done testing because
there's more to ask here and i realize
you may not have answers yet but is
there any sense of whether you'll be
able to guarantee that from moment
ordered online
how long one will have to wait to
receive them and are you going to be
relying on
fedex ups
amazon or the postal service to help
distribute these again really good
questions and we of course want people
to be able to rapidly receive the tests
and people have certainty to know they
can get a test they can feel safe go
into their workplace seeing their family
members sending their kids to school
that's our objective the details of how
we'll be distributed and the mechanisms
will all be coming soon has there been
any actual discussion between the white
house and congress about a possible
supplemental now to deal with omicron i
realize mayors and governors are flush
with cash thanks to all the legislation
passed this year but is there any
discussion yet about possibly another
supplement there's always as you know
from covering congress an open line of
communication uh with members
and leadership about what may be needed
and we're always having that
conversation but right now we believe we
have the resources to get people
vaccinated uh to make those available
and uh part of what you'll hear the
president convey today is how important
it is for individuals to make the choice
to take that step to protect themselves
quick unrelated we're nearing the end of
a year
and in the spirit of the holidays
presidents often
will announce pardons and or
commutations should we be anticipating
anybody in 2022 or 2021 sorry i don't
have anything to preview at this time i
would just reiterate that the president
has every intention of using his
clemency power um and there has been
some reporting which is accurate out
there about uh non-violent looking at
non-violent drug offenders but i don't
have anything to update you on at this
point in time go ahead jackie thanks jen
um these 500 million tests are not
getting to people in time for the
holidays uh and i know that you said you
wish you'd rephrased your december 6th
answer
um but it seemed to discount at the time
which was only two weeks ago the idea of
sending
texts to americans at home
so what made you guys shift gears when
did that happen and is any sort of lack
of urgency and doing that sooner costing
us now i think it's important jackie and
i appreciate you asking the question for
for people at home to understand that
this has all been a building process and
that includes the approval of tests
there are now eight available as of
november that's important because we
needed enough tests to be able to tap
into uh to get the supply it includes
quadrupling not including the
president's speech today our testing
capacity over the course of the last
couple of months it includes the 50
million tests that we made available to
rural community health centers and
community health centers all components
that i talked about exactly on that day
in the briefing if anything it was a
lesson to me to always include the
context and make sure you use every
opportunity of questions you all ask to
do exactly that um but
today what the president is announcing
and this is again to jeff's question and
to yours as well to be clear we're not
sending a test to every single home in
the country we are providing an
opportunity another opportunity or
ability for people to an important one
go on a website and request a test if
their preference is to get that test to
their home not everybody will do that
but we want people who want to do that
who want to get tested who want to
request tests that way to have that
ability to do
obviously this you know new push for for
testing is a big component of the
strategy to combat this this winter
but is there any concern that there
hasn't been enough focus also on
therapeutics given that you have
vaccines in other parts of the world
that don't offer any protection against
omnicron we're lucky in the u.s that
pfizer and moderna do
but this is a virus that's spreading it
in all parts of the world we saw it pop
up here and then just in three weeks
it's the dominant string you're
absolutely right jackie the the the
vaccine and not the vaccine i'm sorry
the virus does not see borders and
obviously fighting the virus getting the
virus under control is going to require
getting it under control globally uh
part of what our objective is an effort
from the us government is to continue to
be the global supplier of vaccine doses
and also a range of
of um of materials
needed to produce vaccines to treat
people who are sick that's certainly is
a part of our objective
push to produce therapeutics you know
it's something like the pill that's
supposed to come out and get that out
with as much urgency as you're
having for the vaccine we will of course
be focused on that but i think it's
important for people to know the best
way to protect yourself is to get
vaccinated and get boosted
and that is the most effective step that
any person living in the united states
or around the world can take and that is
what our priority is on
real quick one last question um you had
said back in i think was june that we
would hear pet news on a day
when uh it was a tough news day and it
was a late show
but yesterday we heard about major being
rehomed a new puppy and a white house
cat so is this like the worst week ever
for the white house
well believe it or not jackie i don't
have time in my schedule to coordinate
with the pet uh folks uh but the pet was
a president uh present from uh the
president's brother uh i met the pet
this morning the pet commander we can
call him by his name um
and he's very adorable he's gonna bring
joy to the president the first family to
all of us probably as well
um and as i think was noted by uh the
first lady's team uh we can expect to
meet the cat a she as i've learned um in
january
go ahead hey jun i'm here in the
district and we're seeing similar
numbers in a number of other
jurisdictions we're seeing all-time
highs in terms of cases not just this
year but for the entirety of
the pandemic
a number of these are also breakthrough
cases we used to hear the administration
talk about how rare these were but there
seems to have been a change in tone
around these uh is it almost inevitable
now is that the view of the
administration that many americans
including vaccinated americans will see
a case a positive case in the next few
weeks well i'm going to let our medical
doctors give an assessment of that we do
expect though and i would echo what they
have said that there to be increases of
cases and increases of breakthrough
cases we are still seeing a significant
amount of protection from even getting
the virus from the vaccines from being
boosted but there are will be
breakthrough cases uh we have we have
breakthrough cases in the white house
i'm sure you will have them in your news
organizations and we're seeing numbers
go up in new york city in dc and other
parts of the country
what we will continue to convey because
we recognize that a lot of people are
sitting at home many of whom are
vaccinated and are scared and
we want to convey accurate information
to them about the effectiveness of the
vaccines and this is a very interesting
uh chart which is why i love charts but
this is an interesting one that fully
vaccinated um this is a this is looking
at average weekly deaths if you look at
the number of fully vaccinated versus
unvaccinated we've seen it have peaks
and valleys but it's 14 times higher for
unvaccinated individuals 14 times more
likely to die of covid than if you're
vaccinated uh i would you know no one
wants to get covet but i think what the
president is conveying is get vaccinated
you may have some light symptoms you may
have most no symptoms that is far
preferable to being hospitalized or even
worse can you think of some of the
protocols that are in place sure i think
a lot of americans have questions about
if they were to test positive or in
close contact what are the protocols
that they should follow what are they in
place here at the white house especially
as it relates to this individual the
tested positives with the presidential
processes
what is their protocol or what is the
president's protocol what is the
protocol for other white house staff
others who are interacting with this
individual well uh well for if somebody
is a close contact so the guidance of
the cdc is if you are close contact you
should be tested five to seven days
five days and seven days post contact we
do three and five days post contact here
at the white house through pcr tests uh
the president has had uh his three day
pcr test yesterday he will have his
five-day five-day pcr test
tomorrow i would also note that as it
relates to our own protocols here
because we of course go over and above
in a lot of ways here uh every time
you're going to travel with the
president or even meet in the oval
office with the president you're
required to be tested that day uh so
there are additional approaches but
they're also regular pro testing
protocols for others who may not be
interacting with the president and we
also wear masks around the building as
well the question on feedback better is
the white house tries to look at a path
forward here
on the child tax credit it seems
inevitable at this point unlikely at
least that millions of americans who
benefited from that child tax credit
from that monthly payment will not get
that in the month of january what is the
white house's message to them and
senator romney has put forward a
proposal that he says would be a
bipartisan pathway or is that something
the white house is looking into well
most importantly the white house the
president's message is that his
preference was to get built back better
passed in december so that people could
have the child tax credit extended a
benefit that
has contributed to cutting child poverty
in half this year and has helped put
money in people's pockets and food on
the table and make sure many many
families could help and make ends meet
during an economic downturn that was
tied to the pandemic and i would say on
the second piece of your question
we are going to work with anybody who is
interested in
taking steps to
lower costs for the american people
whether it's on child care or elder care
or health care
we want to get built back better done
because the comprehensive package is
going to have an enormous impact
according to dozens of economists across
the board uh it would require 60 votes
in order to get individual pieces passed
okay i'm sorry because i don't want you
to miss the speech i'll try to go to
like two more here go ahead uh thanks
jen um will certain groups be
prioritized on the on the testing
website or is it just first-come
first-serve it's a really great question
uh we obviously want to do this in an
equitable way that is how we have
approached every element of our culvert
policy but that is part of what is being
discussed and determined now what are
the procedures that would go into a
place if uh the president did in fact
test positive form
he would follow cdc guidelines
i don't have any predictions of that i
think it depends on whether he would be
symptomatic or not but let's hope that's
not a challenge we will be facing
quickly say whether the staff are the
tested positive tested positive federal
crime variant excuse me i don't have any
additional information
go ahead the last one and then people
can come see me in my office to have to
speak there's a report that you're
considering extending the student loan
relief has a separate deadline can you
comment on that whether that's on the
table or a decision that's been made the
president has not made a decision yet
can you briefly say this asymptomatic
that is sometimes the phrase who's
tested positive but don't have symptoms
you just mean he's not symptomatic he
does not have symptoms yeah he's not
tested positive though because this is
causing yes
apologies um he is not tested positive
he tested negative yesterday as we
indicated and he'll be tested again
tomorrow he is not does not have any
symptoms either well we're reporting
that the fda will authorize both
american fives or pills i would
obviously welcome your confirmation of
that if you give it but more
realistically can you say what rule
having those pills will play in the
overall response how does it change your
view of tackling this with those pills
in hand if they are in fact available
well again i'll just preface um that i'm
not going to of course get ahead of the
fda or the process the gold standard as
we like to say
but certainly having antivirals
available is another component that will
help us fight the virus address the
pandemic help people return to a version
of normal and we will be prepared like
boy scouts and girl scouts to ensure we
are making uh these uh antivirals uh
available to the public all right thanks
everyone
you